Years ago, the senior producer of our program, Brian Reed, worked for a few months in Homer, Alaska as a fish hauler. He still knows some people there.
多年前，我们节目的高级制片人布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）曾在阿拉斯加州的荷马市做过几个月的鱼类搬运工。他至今在那儿还认识一些人。
And that's actually how I heard about this. Basically, there's been this huge political fight going on in the town. Everyone's at each other's throats. They're going crazy on social media. They're up in arms. You know, my friend, who's lived there for decades, three decades, says she's never seen the town like this before.
其实我就是这么听说这件事的。基本上，这个镇上发生了一场巨大的政治斗争。大家都在互相攻击。他们在社交媒体上表现得近乎疯狂。他们全都义愤填膺。你知道，我的朋友在那儿住了几十年，三十年了，她说她从来没见过这个镇子变成这样。
And what's the issue?
那问题出在哪里呢？
Well, it started over illegal immigration, which is a weird thing for Homer to be fighting over, because it doesn't really have any immigrants. Which makes sense, given where Homer is.
嗯，起因是非法移民问题，这对荷马市来说是个很奇怪的争论点，因为这里根本没有什么移民。考虑到荷马市的地理位置，这也在情理之中。
Yeah, Homer's far.
没错，荷马市很偏远。
Yeah, it's literally the end of the road in America. That's like what they're known as.
是的，它简直就是美国道路的尽头。大家就是这么称呼它的。
What does that mean?
那是什么意思？
All right, so say like you were to drive, like cross over the Canadian border from Washington State, say.
好吧，假设你要开车，比如说从华盛顿州穿过加拿大边境。
OK, so I'm in Washington State. I've crossed into Canada.
好的，我现在在华盛顿州。我已经进入加拿大了。
Yeah, you're driving north. You're driving for like 2,500 miles, like it's like basically the same length as crossing the US coast to coast. All right, so you go all the way up Canada that way. You cross back into Alaska. Can you picture that?
对，你一路向北开。你要开大约2500英里，基本上相当于横跨美国东西海岸的距离。好吧，你就那样穿过整个加拿大。然后你再进入阿拉斯加。能想象那个画面吗？
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
All right, then you got like another 11 hours. You're going to drive on to the peninsula, the Kenai Peninsula. You keep driving. And then it's right on this bay called the Kachemak Bay. And stretching out into the bay is this little strip of land called the spit.
好的，然后你还要再开11个小时。你要开上基奈半岛（Kenai Peninsula）。你继续开。然后它就在这个叫卡切马克湾（Kachemak Bay）的海湾边上。伸进海湾里的是一小条陆地，叫做“沙咀”（the spit）。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
That's the end of the road. It's the furthest you can drive in America. And that's Homer.
那就是道路的尽头。那是你在美国能开车到达的最远的地方。那就是荷马市。
What that means, is if you were to cross into the United States from Mexico, this is possibly the least convenient place in America you could end up.
这意味着，如果你从墨西哥进入美国，这可能是你在美国能到达的最不方便的地方。
If you're a member of ISIS, conceivably, I guess, you could fly to Alaska or cross the Bering Strait from Russia. But Brian actually checked with federal authorities, the official from US Immigration and Customs Enforcement who is responsible for Alaska, who said that this does not seem to be happening. And people in Homer know this. They know that illegal immigration is not their issue.
如果你是ISIS的成员，我想你可以想象，也许你可以飞到阿拉斯加或者从俄罗斯穿过白令海峡。但布莱恩实际上和联邦当局核实过，负责阿拉斯加地区的美国移民及海关执法局（ICE）官员表示，这种情况似乎并没有发生。荷马市的人也知道这一点。他们知道非法移民并不是他们的问题所在。
Are you aware of any undocumented immigrants in Homer?
你知道荷马市有任何无证移民吗？
No.
不知道。
Do you have any memory of there being an undocumented immigrant in Homer?
你记忆中有荷马市存在过无证移民吗？
No.
没有。
Have you ever heard of an undocumented immigrant in Homer?
你听说过荷马市有无证移民吗？
No.
没有。
Have you ever heard of an undocumented immigrant being in Homer in your almost 40 years here?
在你住在这里的近40年里，你听说过荷马市有无证移民吗？
No.
没有。
I've asked pretty much everyone I talked to the same question. I heard a couple stories about some people in town who were undocumented at one point or another. But it's rare. I asked the Homer police chief about it. He sent me this email.
我问了几乎所有我交谈过的人同样的问题。我听到过几个关于镇上有些人曾经是无证移民的故事。但这很罕见。我问了荷马市警察局长。他给我发了这封邮件。
Quote, "Brian, Homer is not a destination for immigrants, illegal or legal, and it never has been. The Homer Police Department is not aware of any immigrants in our area. Mark Robel, Chief of Police, Homer Police Department."
引述如下：“布莱恩，荷马市不是移民（无论是非法还是合法）的目的地，过去也从来不是。荷马市警察局不知道我们地区有任何移民。马克·罗贝尔（Mark Robel），荷马市警察局局长。”
That seems pretty categorical.
这看起来非常绝对。
Yeah.
是的。
But people are still fighting over immigrants coming to their town?
但人们还在为来到他们镇上的移民争吵？
Yeah, because it was mentioned in this resolution in the town council that would have welcomed immigrants to Homer.
是的，因为镇议会的一项决议中提到了这一点，该决议本可以欢迎移民来到荷马。
No, do we need a resolution?
不，我们需要一项决议吗？
--in our parking lot.
——在我们的停车场。
No, do we need a resolution?
不，我们需要一项决议吗？
Yeah.
是的。
This is two people from opposing sides of this issue. They're each holding opposing signs in their hands. One's red, one blue. They're standing on a street corner on Pioneer Avenue, the main drag in Homer. They've never met before. Arguing over this.
这是两个持对立观点的人。他们手里各拿着相反的标语牌。一个是红色的，一个是蓝色的。他们站在先锋大道（Pioneer Avenue）的一个街角，那是荷马市的主要街道。他们以前从未见过面。就为了这个在争吵。
I think they need a--
我认为他们需要一个——
You'd like to see in a resolution--
你希望在决议中看到——
I would like to see an inclusive-- Everyone's welcome.
我希望看到一个包容的——欢迎所有人。
Please look--
请看看——
Everyone's welcome. Human rights are civil rights, civil rights are human rights.
欢迎所有人。人权就是公民权利，公民权利就是人权。
Do we have somebody saying that they're not welcome here? Don't we have an America where everybody's welcome? Why are you doing this? Why are you pushing this kind of crap?
我们有人说他们不受欢迎吗？难道我们不是一个欢迎所有人的美国吗？你为什么要这么做？你为什么要推行这种垃圾？
So what got them to this point?
那么是什么让他们到了这个地步？
All right, so basically, after the presidential election, liberals in town, they were not happy that Trump was elected. They were wanting to do something, and they drafted this resolution. And what it said, among other things, was that Homer stood against discrimination, and they mentioned undocumented immigrants and Muslims as people who would be welcome in the city.
好吧，基本上，总统大选后，镇上的自由派对特朗普当选感到不满。他们想做点什么，于是起草了这项决议。其中提到，荷马市反对歧视，他们提到了无证移民和穆斯林是这个城市欢迎的人群。
So, they'd be welcome. Like, what does that mean?
所以，他们会受到欢迎。那是什么意思？
In practice, nothing. It was not a law. It was not even an ordinance. It was a resolution. It was just like a statement of how the town feels as a city, what it stands for.
实际上，什么意思也没有。它不是法律。它甚至不是一项条例。它只是一项决议。它就像是一个城市对自身感受的声明，表明它的立场。
So Trump voters saw that, and they felt--
所以特朗普的支持者看到了，他们感到——
They were pissed, because it was a slap in the face against their guy, basically. And an early version of this resolution actually called Trump out by name a bunch. So, here, I have a little bit of it here. It says like, "Whereas a new administration is in power in Washington, D.C., without a popular mandate, whereas during his campaign, President Donald Trump made statements offensive and harmful to the rights of women, immigrants, religious, racial, and ethnic minorities."
他们很生气，因为这基本上是对他们支持的人的一记耳光。这项决议的早期版本实际上多次点名批评特朗普。看，我这儿有一点内容。它写道：“鉴于华盛顿特区的新政府并非基于民众授权，鉴于特朗普总统在竞选期间发表了冒犯并损害妇女、移民、宗教、种族和少数族裔权利的言论。”
That kind of thing. And the early draft also said that the city would not always cooperate with federal agencies when it came to detaining undocumented immigrants.
大概就是这类东西。早期草案还说，在拘留无证移民方面，市政府将不会总是配合联邦机构。
Wow, so I see why Trump voters were mad.
哇，所以我明白为什么特朗普的支持者会生气了。
Yeah, and there's a lot of Trump voters in Homer. About half the city.
是的，荷马市有很多特朗普的支持者。大约占城市的一半。
So, and then this resolution came before the city council?
所以，然后这项决议被提交到了市议会？
Yeah.
是的。
So at this time, we can take public comment on any matter on the agenda. Please come forward and sign in.
现在我们可以对议程上的任何事项进行公众评论。请上前登记。
People, like, descended on this town council meeting in droves, back in February. The council chambers were packed. People were lined up against the walls. They were sitting on the floor. They were lined up out the door and down the hall, into an overflow room, where they piped the meeting in. It was broadcast on the radio.
二月份的时候，人们成群结队地涌向市议会会议。议会厅里挤满了人。人们沿着墙排队。他们坐在地板上。他们排到了门外，沿着走廊一直排到了一个溢出室，会议内容通过广播传到那里。会议还在电台上进行了直播。
I talked to bunch of people-- people actually listened to it on the radio, all over town, which was amazing to me. It was intense. It was very emotional. Four people have cried as they were talking to me about this meeting, months after it happened. It was that emotional on both sides of the issue.
我和好多人聊过——人们真的在收音机里听了会议，全镇都在听，这让我很惊讶。气氛很紧张。非常情绪化。有四个人在跟我谈论这次会议时哭了，尽管这已经是好几个月后的事了。双方在问题上都非常激动。
Why was it so emotional?
为什么会这么情绪化？
I just think this meeting was kind of a moment where everyone in town declared for the first time where they stood on this, publicly, to their neighbors.
我只是认为这次会议是一个时刻，镇上的每个人都第一次公开向邻居宣布了他们在这个问题上的立场。
If you vote yes on this, I'll be your worst nightmare. Because I'll push for a recall.
如果你对这个投赞成票，我将成为你最糟糕的噩梦。因为我会推动罢免。
People at the meeting were overwhelmingly against the resolution.
会议上的人绝大多数都反对这项决议。
You bring in illegals, OK, by definition, they're criminals. OK, they live in the underworld. They don't have a stake in the game as we do. About the first time somebody gets raped or killed, I hope they come straight after the Homer City Council and sue the City to the point of bankruptcy. If you make this a magnet for that type of people, then, you know, shame on you.
你引进非法移民，好吗，根据定义，他们就是罪犯。好吗，他们生活在地下世界。他们不像我们这样对社区有归属感。如果第一次有人被强奸或杀害，我希望他们直接起诉荷马市议会，让城市破产。如果你让这里成为这类人的磁铁，那么，你们就丢脸吧。
So people are really scared.
所以人们真的很害怕。
Yeah, and angry. And the people on the other side, they felt scared, seeing what their neighbors think and what they were willing to say-- because they felt like people were being hateful and discriminatory-- or what they said aloud at the meeting.
是的，而且很愤怒。另一边的人则感到害怕，因为看到了他们的邻居在想什么，以及他们愿意说出什么——因为他们觉得人们在散布仇恨和歧视——或者他们在会议上大声说出的话。
Three weeks ago, I stood on the corner of Heath and Pioneer with a sign that read Muslim immigrant, Homer local.
三周前，我站在希思（Heath）和先锋路（Pioneer）的拐角处，举着一个写着“穆斯林移民，荷马本地人”的牌子。
This is a guy named Shamir. He's possibly the only Muslim in town.
这是一个叫沙米尔（Shamir）的人。他可能是镇上唯一的穆斯林。
In response, drivers made obscene hand gestures, called me a freak, and this same car whipped past three times to splash as much rain water on me as possible. I'm here to refute anyone who believes that we don't need this kind of resolution, because we don't have these kind of problems in Homer. Let me assure you that we do.
作为回应，司机们做着淫秽的手势，叫我怪胎，同一辆车从我身边飞驰而过三次，尽可能多地把雨水溅到我身上。我在这里是为了驳斥任何认为我们不需要这种决议的人，因为我们在荷马没有这种问题。让我向你们保证，我们确实有。
The resolution was voted down, but it didn't stop there. After that, there was a recall election which failed. That whole email scandal. The ACLU got involved with a lawsuit against the city.
这项决议最终被否决了，但事情并没有就此结束。之后，举行了一场罢免选举，但失败了。还有整个邮件丑闻。美国公民自由联盟（ACLU）介入了对城市的诉讼。
OK, so here's what I'm getting from this. People are really mad at each other and they are not stopping this conflict, and it is all about immigration.
好了，我从这里得到的信息是这样的。人们对彼此非常愤怒，他们没有停止冲突，而这一切都是关于移民问题的。
That's how it started at least, yeah.
至少这就是开始，是的。
In this town that doesn't actually have an immigration problem.
在这个实际上并没有移民问题的镇子上。
Exactly. And actually, you know, I pointed this out to people in Homer as I talked to them. And you know, I get all sorts of different reactions. Like some people definitely saw the absurdity in it. Some people thought it wasn't crazy to think that if that resolution was passed, or if Homer somehow became a sanctuary city, they thought, sure, undocumented immigrants or refugees could totally start coming here.
正是如此。而且，你知道，我在和荷马市的人交谈时向他们指出了这一点。你知道，我得到了各种不同的反应。有些人确实看到了它的荒谬之处。有些人认为，如果该决议通过，或者荷马以某种方式成为了庇护城市，那么无证移民或难民完全可能开始来到这里，这种想法并不疯狂。
And then plenty-- you know, a lot of people told me like, yeah, this is not a fight, actually, over immigration. It's over something bigger. And I talked to this one woman, Hannah. She's a boat captain. She put it, I don't know-- I thought the best of anybody. She said this.
然后很多人——你知道，很多人告诉我，是的，这实际上不是一场关于移民的斗争。它关乎更大的问题。我和一位女士聊过，汉娜（Hannah）。她是一位船长。我不知道——我觉得她总结得最好。她是这么说的。
It's like we're acting out this play that reflects our deepest anxieties, but none of it's based on anything real. It's based on what-ifs. It's based on I don't think the same way as you. Things that could happen, things that have happened in other places, fear. And the fear of something becoming real. But none of it is based on things that are actually happening here.
这就像我们在演一出戏，反映了我们内心深处的焦虑，但这一切都不是基于任何真实的东西。它是基于“如果……怎么办”。它基于“我的想法和你不一样”。那些可能发生的事情，那些在其他地方发生过的事情，恐惧。以及对某些事情变成现实的恐惧。但没有任何东西是基于这里正在发生的真实事情。
Right now, all over this country, lots of people are wary of immigrants, wanting something done about immigrants, they're fearful of immigrants, whether or not there are immigrants in their lives. Today on our program, we have stories of two places where people got really upset about immigrants, even though immigration did not seem like it was the most important thing there going on at all.
现在，在这个国家的各个地方，很多人都对移民保持警惕，想要对移民采取行动，他们害怕移民，无论他们的生活中是否真的有移民。今天我们的节目中，我们有两个地方的故事，那里的民众对移民非常不满，尽管移民似乎根本不是当地最重要的事情。
One of these places is Homer, a small town that is about as remote as you can get-- as you've heard-- with almost no immigrants. The other one's in the suburbs, in the densely developed east coast-- Rockville, Maryland, with lots of immigrants, documented and undocumented. And what's interesting in both places is that we see why people's feelings on this issue just spiraled bigger, and bigger, and bigger, beyond the facts at hand. From WBEZ in Chicago, it's This American Life. Stay with us.
其中一个地方是荷马市，正如你所听到的，这是一个极其偏远的小镇，几乎没有移民。另一个在郊区，在人口稠密的东海岸——马里兰州的罗克维尔（Rockville），那里有大量的移民，包括合法和无证移民。有趣的是，在这两个地方，我们都能看出为什么人们在这个问题上的情绪超出了现有事实，变得越来越激烈。这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台的《美国生活》（This American Life）。请继续收听。
Act One, Fear. So Brian spent some time in Homer, Alaska talking to all kinds of people involved in this debate that the town has been having over whether it should welcome immigrants or not. And he became especially interested in this one guy.
第一幕，恐惧。布莱恩在阿拉斯加州的荷马市待了一段时间，与所有参与这场争论的人进行了交谈，讨论这个镇子是否应该欢迎移民。他对比这一个人特别感兴趣。
I found this guy, because he testified at that Homer City Council meeting, the one where everyone was so upset. I spoke to lots of people who attended the meeting, or listened to it. What everyone had in common was that they all seemed so sure of their sides, like of course I support the ideas in this resolution, or of course I don't. Know one sounded uncertain about it. Until I met this guy.
我找到了这个人，因为他在那次荷马市议会会议上作了证，就是大家都非常激动的那次。我采访了许多参加会议或收听了会议的人。他们共同点是，他们似乎都非常确信自己的立场，比如我当然支持这项决议中的观点，或者我当然不支持。没有人听起来对此感到不确定。直到我遇到了这个人。
Believe it or not, I'm kind of an emotional person. When I see people in conflict with each other, it just kind of upsets me, and I'd really rather not deal with it, so I don't have to take any more antacids.
信不信由你，我其实是个很感性的人。当我看到人们发生冲突时，我就会感到心烦，我真的不想去处理这些事，这样我就不用再吃更多的抗酸剂了。
This is Ben Tyrer, who generally avoids politics and news for that very reason.
这是本·泰勒（Ben Tyrer），正是因为这个原因，他通常会避开政治和新闻。
News stresses me out, if we're being honest.
老实说，新闻让我感到压力。
I hope we are.
我希望我们是坦诚的。
Yeah.
是的。
Ben Tyrer, jazz musician and janitor at Kenai Peninsula College, and to me, the most interesting person in town, because he's the only person I met who seemed to actually be struggling to figure out what side to be on. Ben was born and raised in Homer.
本·泰勒，爵士乐手，基奈半岛学院的清洁工。对我来说，他是镇上最有趣的人，因为他是我见过的唯一一个似乎在努力弄清楚自己该站在哪一边的人。本是在荷马土生土长的。
Now he's 27, married, with a two-year-old daughter, which has given him a talent for dad humor that's ahead of his years. My favorite joke from his Facebook page-- "What comes after Colin Firth? Colin Thecond." When all these people in Homer were suddenly up in arms over whether to welcome immigrants, Ben didn't want to jump to any unfair conclusions.
现在他27岁，已婚，有一个两岁的女儿，这让他拥有了一种超越年龄的冷幽默天赋。我在他Facebook页面上最喜欢的笑话是——“Colin Firth（科林·费尔斯）后面是什么？Colin Thecond（科林·第二）”。当荷马市所有人都突然为是否欢迎移民而义愤填膺时，本不想草率地得出不公平的结论。
I'm not just going to willy-nilly make generalizations about an entire group of people based on my feelings. We really have to be careful of that kind of thing, because in the past, that has led to some pretty unpleasant consequences. Before I make a decision like that, I really need to be sure that I am coming from what I consider to be an informed place.
我不会仅仅凭自己的感觉就随意地对整个群体进行概括。我们真的必须小心这种事情，因为在过去，这导致了一些非常不愉快的后果。在做出那样的决定之前，我真的需要确保我是从我认为知情的位置出发的。
Ben considers himself a moderate. Says he's voted pretty evenly for both parties. Last year, he was into Bernie Sanders. But when the presidential election came around, he ended up just sitting it out, because he found it too unpleasant. He says he never paid attention to immigration as an issue. It was not something that really crossed his mind until the resolution.
本认为自己是个温和派。他说他在两个党派之间投得相当均匀。去年，他喜欢伯尼·桑德斯（Bernie Sanders）。但当总统大选到来时，他最终还是选择了弃权，因为他觉得这太令人不快了。他说他从未关注过移民问题。直到那项决议出来，这都不是他真正在意的事情。
It was all over social media, being talked about all around town. So he read it. And it scared him.
社交媒体上到处都在谈论这件事，全镇也都在谈论。所以他读了它。这让他感到害怕。
Ben describes the feeling he got as an amorphous blob of fear. That's what crept up inside him. And he immediately thought of this story he'd stumbled across a few weeks before, maybe in his Facebook feed, or just poking around online, about this one attack in Europe.
本形容他得到的感觉是一种模糊的恐惧团块。这就是在他心里蔓延的感觉。他立刻想起了几周前他在网上偶然发现的一个故事，可能是在他的Facebook订阅里，或者只是在网上乱逛时看到的，关于欧洲发生的一次袭击。
Cologne. It was Cologne that happened in Germany, the New Year's thing.
科隆。那是发生在德国的科隆，新年发生的那个事件。
It was an incident from New Year's, the year before, 2016, when hundreds of women in Cologne, Germany filed reports with the police saying they'd been sexually assaulted while they were in big crowds during celebrations. Many of the women said that the men who'd assaulted them were Arabic speakers and appeared to be from North Africa. It was a very disturbing event which had shaken Germany, and it shook Ben too.
那是前一年，即2016年新年发生的一起事件，当时德国科隆有数百名妇女向警方报案，称她们在庆祝活动的人群中遭到性侵。许多妇女说，袭击她们的男人说着阿拉伯语，看起来像是来自北非。这是一起非常令人不安的事件，震惊了德国，也震惊了本。
Wow, in Europe? Of all places, this is happening in Europe? Like I said, I hadn't really been paying attention. And it just shocked me.
哇，在欧洲？在所有地方中，这竟然发生在欧洲？就像我说的那样，我并没有真正关注。这让我感到震惊。
So you hadn't followed the news through like the attacks in Paris, or the Charlie Hebdo attacks? You just hadn't been watching the news on that stuff?
那你没有关注像巴黎袭击或查理周刊袭击那样的新闻吗？你只是没有关注这些事？
No.
没有。
I'm not judging you, I'm just asking.
我不是在评判你，我只是在问。
No, like I said, no.
没有，就像我说的，没有。
So that's what was fresh in Ben's mind when he read the resolution-- Cologne. And it freaked him out.
所以这就是本在读到那项决议时脑海中挥之不去的记忆——科隆事件。这让他吓坏了。
Even though Ben admits that immigration is not exactly the biggest issue in his town, no one is sharpening their knives and thinking of Homer, he tells me. And even though much of the resolution was about fending off discrimination and protecting vulnerable people, things Ben agrees with in principle, when it came to welcoming undocumented immigrants, to Ben it seemed like the city might be opening a door to people who could possibly do harm.
尽管本承认移民问题在他们镇上算不上最大的问题，没有人在磨刀霍霍地想着荷马市，他告诉我。尽管那项决议大部分内容是关于抵制歧视和保护弱势群体——本原则上同意这些观点——但在欢迎无证移民的问题上，本觉得这个城市可能会给那些可能造成伤害的人敞开大门。
Everyone around him was so riled up about this. It felt irresponsible not to have an informed opinion on it. So Ben started staying up late, night after night, spending hours on the computer long after his wife went to bed, doing something I imagine few of the millions of people who are up late on the internet every night are doing-- researching global migration.
周围的每个人都为此感到愤怒。不对此发表知情意见似乎是不负责任的。所以本开始熬夜，一晚又一晚，在妻子睡觉后，在电脑前花了几个小时，做了一件我想象中每晚在网上熬夜的数百万人中很少有人做的事——研究全球移民问题。
He doesn't have a printer. So he'd go back and forth to his parents' house, which is right in front of his place, to print out articles and reports. Ben may not be a big news guy, but he does like to research. He's been slowly building the house he and his family now live in, pretty much singlehandedly, with no experience in construction, based largely off research he's done online.
他没有打印机。所以他来回奔波于他父母的家，那就在他住处前面，去打印文章和报告。本可能不是个新闻发烧友，但他确实喜欢做研究。他现在住的房子是他和家人几乎单枪匹马建起来的，没有任何建筑经验，主要就是靠他自己在网上做的研究。
So he figured he could take those research skills and apply them to this question of whether immigration is a good thing for a place to encourage or bad.
所以他想他可以用这些研究技能来处理这个问题：鼓励移民来到这里是好事还是坏事。
And did you feel like you had an open mind about it? Did you feel like--
你觉得你对这件事心态开放吗？你觉得——
If we're being honest, I didn't have an open mind about it. But I knew that, and I knew that that's not a good thing to have if you are trying to have an actual view of what's going on in the world instead of just what you want to have going on in the world. So I kind of took it upon myself to question-- actually question-- everything that I think.
如果我们坦诚的话，我的心态并不开放。但我知道这一点，我也知道，如果你试图对世界上正在发生的事情有一个真实的看法，而不是仅仅想要发生什么，这种心态是不好的。所以我自己承担了质疑——实际上是质疑——我所想的一切的责任。
Ben set out to do something many of us believe we've done in our own lives, but I think, if we're being honest, rarely actually have. He set out to do what a good citizen in a democracy is supposed to do-- delve into the facts, aware of your preconceptions, but with as much of an open mind as possible and form a knowledgeable opinion based on the evidence.
本着手去做许多人相信我们在自己的生活中已经做过的事情，但我想，如果我们坦诚的话，很少有人真正做到过。他着手做了一名民主制度下的优秀公民应该做的事情——深入挖掘事实，意识到自己的成见，但尽可能以开放的心态，根据证据形成知情的意见。
And when he did that, it took him to a place that really surprised him, and made him question how he views the world. Ben opens his laptop and tries to replicate for me best he can remember how he began. He started with a simple Google search-- something like "What's the refugee situation in Europe?"
当他这样做时，这把他带到了一个真正让他惊讶的地方，并让他质疑自己看待世界的方式。本打开笔记本电脑，尽量向我还原他开始时的样子。他从一个简单的谷歌搜索开始——类似于“欧洲的难民情况如何？”
Migrant crisis-- migration to Europe explained in seven charts. The EU and the refugee crisis. They like to use the word crisis a lot, which was kind of a red flag.
移民危机——用七张图表解释欧洲的移民问题。欧盟和难民危机。他们喜欢用“危机”这个词，这算是一个警示信号。
And before he knew it, he was down a rabbit hole of frightening stories-- stories about "no go zones" outside Paris. Immigrant neighborhoods, where native French people supposedly could no longer enter. He bumped into more stories about the sexual assaults in Cologne.
在他意识到之前，他就掉进了令人恐惧的故事兔子洞里——关于巴黎郊外“禁区”（no-go zones）的故事。那里是移民社区，据说法国本地人已经无法进入了。他又看到了更多关于科隆性侵案的故事。
[WOMAN SPEAKING GERMAN IN VIDEO CLIP]
[视频片段中一名妇女用德语讲话]
Watching and reading all this stuff, late at night, in the dark Alaskan winter, trying to forge an understanding of a place very far away that Ben has never been-- Europe-- and of people from even further away than that, that he has never met, Ben felt upset and worried. But also not entirely sure whether he could trust the information he was getting.
在黑暗的阿拉斯加冬天，深夜看着和读着这一切，试图弄清楚一个非常遥远、本从未去过的地方——欧洲——以及比那更遥远、本从未见过的人们，本感到心烦意乱，忧心忡忡。但也并不完全确定他是否能相信他得到的信息。
The immediate gut reaction was, that's awful. But it's also like, OK, they're using these specifically to get that gut reaction out of people, to really get people to one side.
即时的直觉反应是，那太糟糕了。但同时也觉得，好吧，他们正利用这些东西来激起人们的这种直觉反应，真正地把人们引向一边。
You've got that kind of sub-narrative or something going on in your head, or sub commentary as you're reading through this stuff? Where's this coming from? What's the agenda of it?
你脑子里有那种次级叙事或类似的东西，或者当你阅读这些东西时有次级评论吗？这是从哪里来的？它的议程是什么？
Exactly. Who is benefiting from me seeing this? Is it purely altruistic? Or is there something else going on?
正是如此。谁从我看到这些东西中受益？这是完全无私的吗？还是另有隐情？
So Ben sought out information from other perspectives. He watched interviews with refugees and asylum seekers, telling their stories firsthand, of fleeing persecution or war in their home countries and embarking on harrowing journeys to Europe.
所以本寻求了其他视角的各种信息。他观看了难民和寻求庇护者的采访，听他们讲述第一手故事，讲述如何从家乡逃离迫害或战争，并踏上前往欧洲的惊心动魄的旅程。
This guy, he seems like a nice guy who was just trying to do the right thing. You know, I'd be more than willing to help a person like that. He's a very brave man.
这个人，他看起来是个好人，只是试图做正确的事。你知道，我更愿意帮助像那样的人。他是个非常勇敢的人。
But then he'd feel unsure about that stuff too.
但随后他对那些东西也感到不确定。
If you watch this stuff kind of stuff enough for a long enough period of time, there's almost this paranoid reaction that you get. Is this real? Is this staged? It's a really dark, strange place you get to in your own head when you watch enough of these.
如果你看这种东西看的时间够长，你几乎会产生一种偏执的反应。这是真的吗？这是演出来的吗？当你看了足够多这些东西时，你的脑子里会进入一个非常黑暗、奇怪的地方。
Remember, Ben was new to news. I was basically a baby learning to walk, he tells me. His understanding was that publications like The New York Times and The Washington Post had a bad rap, so he didn't really spend too much time there.
记住，本是个新闻初学者。我基本上是个刚学走路的婴儿，他告诉我。他的理解是，《纽约时报》和《华盛顿邮报》这类出版物声名狼藉，所以他并没有真正在那里花太多时间。
He would go to a site like the BBC, but worried maybe they were giving him a liberal bent. So then he'd go to a site like this conservative Canadian one he found, The Rebel. But he knew he couldn't fully trust that either. The whole experience was head spinning. So he started digging up primary sources as well.
他会去像BBC这样的网站，但担心也许他们会给他一个自由派的偏见。所以他会去像他发现的这个保守派加拿大网站，《叛逆者》（The Rebel）。但他知道他也不能完全信任那个。整个经历让人头晕目眩。所以他也开始挖掘主要来源。
He's got a bunch of papers that he's printed out for me, documents and reports that he's compiled. He went to Cornell Law School's website to read up on immigration law, trying to figure out if sanctuary cities were legal. He determined that they were not. He also pulled crime stats directly from the German Ministry of the Interior.
他给我打印了一堆文件，他汇编的文档和报告。他去了康奈尔法学院的网站查询移民法，试图弄清楚庇护城市是否合法。他断定它们是不合法的。他还直接从德国联邦内政部调取了犯罪统计数据。
He did that after reading this one article which he shows me with the headline, "Report, Migrants Committing Disproportionately High Crime in Germany."
他是在读了这篇文章后这样做的，他向我展示了标题——“报告：移民在德国犯下的罪行高得不成比例”。
What source is that from?
那个来源是哪里的？
This is-- oh, Breitbart.
这是——哦，布赖特巴特（Breitbart）。
Breitbart, the right wing nationalist site formerly run by Donald Trump's chief strategist, Steve Bannon, which is proudly anti-immigration. The article states that crime rates would have remained static in Germany if not for migrants coming in-- that the country recorded an extra 402,000 crimes by immigrants since 2014.
布赖特巴特，那个曾由特朗普首席策略师史蒂夫·班农（Steve Bannon）运营的右翼民族主义网站，它自豪地反对移民。文章指出，如果不是因为移民涌入，德国的犯罪率本会保持不变——自2014年以来，该国记录了40.2万起由移民犯下的额外罪行。
How do you feel about Breitbart? I mean, that's a place people have a lot of feelings about, in terms of as a news source. I'm curious what you feel?
你对布赖特巴特感觉如何？我是说，作为一个新闻来源，人们对那个地方有很多感受。我很好奇你的感受？
Yeah. If I had only used Breitbart, I would have been a little bit more suspicious.
是的。如果我只用了布赖特巴特，我会更怀疑一点。
Ben says he went to the website for Germany's interior ministry specifically to fact check this article's claims that crime by immigrants has increased dramatically. He also has this other document that he discovered online, which he says put him over the edge in terms of making his decision.
本说他专门去了德国联邦内政部的网站，以核实这篇文章关于移民犯罪大幅增加的说法。他还拥有他在网上发现的另一份文件，他说这份文件让他下定决心做出了决定。
Let's see, what is this? Gatestone Institute.
让我看看，这是什么？盖特斯通研究所（Gatestone Institute）。
It's a long report by a think tank I've never heard of called the Gatestone Institute, titled The Islamization of Germany, listing crimes and bad acts, supposedly committed by migrants, and specifically Muslims, in the country. It goes nearly day by day through 2016, enumerating ugly incident after ugly incident of flashings, stabbings, shootings, sexual assaults.
这是一份由我从未听说过的智库盖特斯通研究所撰写的长篇报告，标题是《德国的伊斯兰化》，列出了据称由移民，特别是穆斯林，在该国犯下的罪行和恶行。它几乎按天追溯了2016年，逐一列举了丑陋的事件，包括闪露、捅人、枪击、性侵。
I mean, the first one right off the list is just January 1st, mobs of Muslim men of "Arabic or North African origin" sexually assaulted hundreds of women in Cologne and other German cities.
我的意思是，名单上的第一条就是1月1日，成群的“阿拉伯或北非裔”穆斯林男子在科隆和其他德国城市性侵了数百名妇女。
Again, the Cologne attacks, which had set Ben off on this journey.
同样是科隆袭击事件，开启了本的这段旅程。
Cologne Police Chief Wolfgang Albers called it a completely new dimension of crime. And that's just the first one on the list. There are 19 pages here of stuff like that. Mmm.
科隆警察局长沃尔夫冈·阿尔贝斯（Wolfgang Albers）称这是一种完全全新的犯罪维度。而那只是名单上的第一条。这里有19页这样的东西。嗯。
Wait, why the "mmm"? Or whatever noise you just made.
等等，为什么要发出“嗯”？或者你刚才发出的那种声音。
Well, I haven't really gone through a lot of this information since I used it, and kind of going back through it again, it's kind of-- it's making me a little bit, you know, uneasy, a little bit upset. Trying to keep it under wraps, but--
嗯，自从我使用它以来，我并没有真正翻阅过很多这些信息，现在回头再看，它有点——让我有点，你知道，不安，有点心烦。试图控制住它，但是——
Right now, you're feeling upset and trying to, like, tamp it down.
现在，你感到心烦，并试图，比如，压制它。
A little bit, yeah.
有一点，是的。
Because you feel like you're feeling something ugly. When you read this stuff, you feel something ugly.
因为你觉得你在感受一些丑陋的东西。当你读到这些东西时，你感到一些丑陋的东西。
Yeah, And I don't like it. Like I said, I've read a lot--
是的。我不喜欢它。就像我说的，我已经读了很多——
Do you feel scared of people based on their ethnicity or background?
你是否根据人们的种族或背景对他们感到害怕？
Yeah. I mean, it's kind of an age-old conflict between your brain and your heart. My brain is telling me to at least be cautious, to really keep an eye on this, and to keep an eye on-- to keep an eye on them, for lack of a better sentiment. And then there's my heart that says, these are people too. I mean, if the shoe was on the other foot, if the United States was a third world, war torn country, I would do whatever it took to get my family out of here, legally or illegally.
是的。我是说，这在某种程度上是你的大脑和内心之间古老的冲突。我的大脑告诉我至少要谨慎，要真正盯着这事，盯着——盯着他们，缺乏一个更好的说法。然后是我的内心，它说，这些也是人。我是说，如果换位思考一下，如果美国是一个第三世界、饱受战争蹂躏的国家，我会不惜一切代价让我的家人离开这里，无论是以合法还是非法的方式。
Like it really-- he was, like, really torn up.
这真的——他非常痛苦。
Ben's wife, Hope, said she was not prepared for how emotional this decision would become.
本的妻子霍普（Hope）说，她没有准备好这个决定会变得如此情绪化。
It was an intense week.
那是紧张的一周。
Was it really?
真的吗？
Yeah, it was.
是的，确实。
Hope and Ben have known each other for seven years. They've been married for three. And she says it's up there among the most intense things they've gone through as a couple, close to having a baby and building a house. Immigration into Homer. It took them both aback.
霍普和本认识七年了。他们结婚三年。她说，这是他们作为夫妻经历过的最紧张的事情之一，接近于生孩子和建房子。移民进入荷马。这对他们俩来说都出乎意料。
I didn't expect it to be that draining.
我没想到会那么令人精疲力竭。
Finally, after about a week of reading, and searching, and thinking, and talking it through, Ben arrived at a conclusion. He decided that he was opposed to the resolution.
最终，经过大约一周的阅读、搜索、思考和讨论，本得出了一个结论。他决定反对这项决议。
I prefer to air on the side of caution in this case. At this specific time in history, I believe a certain amount of caution is warranted.
在这种情况下，我宁愿选择谨慎。在历史上这个特定的时刻，我相信有一定程度的谨慎是有必要的。
And then, he also decided--
然后，他还决定——
I was going to bring it before the council.
我要把它提到议会。
Microphones are already on. State your name.
麦克风已经开了。报出你的名字。
My name is Ben Tyrer.
我的名字是本·泰勒。
Hello, Ben. Welcome.
你好，本。欢迎。
You'll have to excuse me. I just got off work a little while ago. I don't know what all's been covered here.
你们得原谅我。我刚下班不久。我不知道这里已经覆盖了什么。
Ben got to the February council meeting near the end. He'd had to work late at the college, where he's a janitor, right next door. He says he pumped himself up to speak while he was mopping bathrooms. When he got to town hall, the public had been speaking for more than three hours. The council members were exhausted. The place was still packed. He was the last person to address the council.
本在二月的议会会议接近尾声时赶到。他在学院（他在那里做清洁工）不得不加班，那就在隔壁。他说他在打扫卫生间时一直在给自己鼓劲。当他到达市政厅时，公众发言已经进行了三个多小时。议员们精疲力竭。现场依然挤满了人。他是最后一位向议会发言的人。
I don't necessarily think-- what we have to consider is what these people will be-- you know what, I'm not going to talk with emotion anymore. I'm just going to read a few of these things that I've brought with me, because I think facts outweigh emotion. This is from Breitbart. I found it on The Drudge Report web site. "A massive migrant crime wave is surging across Germany."
我并不一定认为——我们必须考虑的是这些人将是——你知道吗，我不再带有情绪说话了。我只是要读几条我带来的东西，因为我认为事实胜于雄辩。这是来自布赖特巴特的。我在德拉吉报道（The Drudge Report）网站上发现的。“大规模移民犯罪浪潮正在德国蔓延。”
I wanted to just present something a little bit more solid. I didn't necessarily want to just go in and say this is good or this is bad. I just wanted to present information to the people listening and to the council. And I brought copies of all the stuff that I have here.
我只是想呈现一些更扎实的东西。我不一定要进去说这很好或者这很坏。我只是想向收听的人和议会呈现信息。我把我这里所有的东西都带了复印件。
The data reveals that without migrants considered, crime rate in Germany would have remained roughly static since 2014...
数据显示，如果不考虑移民，自2014年以来，德国的犯罪率大致保持不变……
Ben read what he could from his research. And then, before he knew it, his three minute time limit was up.
本读了他从研究中能读到的东西。然后，在他意识到之前，他三分钟的发言时间到了。
The womans rights minister declared there are now areas in our country where women can no longer go...
妇女权利部长宣称我们的国家现在有妇女无法再去的地区……
[BEEPING]
[哔声]
Thank you Ben...
谢谢你，本……
The mayor cut him off.
市长打断了他。
If you would like to leave any of the material with the clerk, she'd be happy to enter those into the public record for what you weren't allowed to finish there. Anybody else from the community that would like to come forward?
如果你想把材料留给书记员，她很乐意把那些你还没来得及读完的内容列入公共记录。社区里还有谁想上前发言吗？
After the meeting, Ben got in this car. He'd done what he set out to do. But as he drove home, he realized, he still felt very mixed up about it.
会议结束后，本上了这辆车。他完成了他打算做的事情。但当他开车回家时，他意识到，他仍然对这件事感到非常困惑。
Honestly, after I came home that night, I was so torn up about the decision, I was actually crying a little bit.
老实说，那天晚上回家后，我对这个决定感到非常痛苦，实际上我当时哭了。
Why were you crying?
你为什么哭？
Believe it or not, it kind of changed my world view a little bit. Because honestly, I have this part of me that I want everybody to get along, and I want all of us to be together, and just-- I don't think it's realistic necessarily. But the utopian ideal. I just want us all to-- we are the world, kumbaya, holding hands.
信不信由你，它在某种程度上改变了我的世界观。因为老实说，我内心有这样一部分，我希望每个人都能和睦相处，我希望我们所有人能团结在一起，只是——我不认为这一定是现实的。但那种乌托邦式的理想。我只是希望我们所有人——我们是世界，团结友爱，手拉手。
And the fact that I was making a decision to kind of crack down on a certain group of people really tore me up, bad. This hope in everybody, that eventually we'll all just kind of get along. I don't know if it's possible. And it's just kind of sad, really.
而我正在做出一个决定去打击特定一群人的事实，确实让我非常痛苦。对每个人的这种希望，最终我们都会和睦相处。我不知道这是否可能。这真的让人有点悲伤。
What did you say to your wife when you came home?
你回家时对你妻子说了什么？
I just asked her do you think I did the right thing?
我只是问她，你觉得我做对了吗？
He was saying, you know-- was this the right thing to do? Was this the right decision? It was an interesting night. We were up late that night.
他当时说，你知道——这是正确的事情吗？这是正确的决定吗？那是一个有趣的夜晚。那天晚上我们熬得很晚。
He said he was crying a little bit?
他说他当时哭了？
Yeah, little bit. I think that was maybe the third time I've ever seen Ben cry. Yeah, he doesn't cry. So, I knew it was a very serious thing for him.
是的，一点点。我想那大概是我第三次看到本哭。是的，他不怎么哭。所以，我知道这对他来说是一件非常严肃的事情。
One day, as I was leaving one of my interviews with Ben, he was giving me the articles and reports he'd printed out. I would love to take this stuff.
有一天，当我离开对本的采访时，他把打印出来的文章和报告给了我。我很想拿走这些东西。
Did you want to--
你想——
I would love it. And then he said this.
我很喜欢。然后他说了这个。
I would love for you to tell me that I'm wrong. If you can read this stuff and tell me that I'm wrong, I would love that.
如果你能告诉我我是错的，我会很高兴。如果你能读这些东西并告诉我我是错的，我会很高兴的。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah, because, man, I don't like thinking this way about people.
是的，因为，伙计，我不喜欢这样想别人。
OK, well I can do that. Like I could-- well, I can try. Maybe I'll go home after my trip here and see if we can fact check some of the stuff.
好吧，我能做到。比如我能——好吧，我能试试。也许在我这次旅行回家后，我会看看我们能不能核实一下其中的一些东西。
Please, please do.
请，请一定要核实。
So I did.
所以我做了。
Damien, in Berlin, can you hear Ben?
达米安（Damien），在柏林，你能听到本吗？
Good morning, Ben. Good evening for you. How are you doing?
早上好，本。晚上好，你那边。你好吗？
I am quite well. How are you doing, sir?
我很好。你好吗，先生？
Because of his research, Ben now had this whole new view of reality that was making him kind of miserable. And he still had doubts and questions. So it seemed worth double checking what he'd learned.
由于他的研究，本现在有了一个全新的现实观，这让他感到有点痛苦。他仍然有怀疑和问题。所以核实他所学到的东西似乎是值得的。
I've never been to Germany. I'm not an expert on the migration situation in Europe. So a few weeks after I met Ben in Homer, I arranged for him to have a conversation with someone who is-- someone who's actually in the place Ben was looking to-- to try to understand the impacts immigration can have.
我从未去过德国。我不是欧洲移民局势的专家。所以在荷马见到本几周后，我安排他和一位专家进行了一次交谈——一位实际上就在本试图理解的地方的人——试图理解移民可能产生的影响。
Damien McGuinness, a BBC correspondent in Berlin. He spent 14 years reporting in Germany, and one of his main focuses in the last several years has been the influx of migrants into the country. I know the BBC was one of the sources Ben wasn't sure if he could trust, because it might have a liberal bent.
达米安·麦金尼斯（Damien McGuinness），BBC驻柏林记者。他在德国报道了14年，过去几年来他的主要重点之一就是移民涌入该国。我知道BBC是本不确定是否能信任的来源之一，因为可能带有自由派偏见。
So I asked him if he believed Damien. And he said he'd definitely be looking up what he said afterwards, fact checking the fact checking. But he seemed to take seriously that Damien lives in Germany, and has reported a lot on these issues. So Damien went into a studio in Berlin, and Ben went into one in Homer.
所以我问他是否相信达米安。他说他事后肯定会去查证他所说的内容，核实核实。但他似乎认真对待了达米安住在德国，并且在这些问题上做了大量报道的事实。所以达米安进了柏林的一个工作室，本进了荷马的一个工作室。
We're very far away from each other, so it's a pleasure to talk to you on the other side of the world.
我们离彼此很远，所以能在地球的另一端和你交谈是我的荣幸。
You know, I'm just a small town boy. This is the craziest thing that's ever happened to me.
你知道，我只是个小镇男孩。这是我有生以来发生的最疯狂的事情。
I sent Damien all the research Ben had given me beforehand-- the articles and reports and statistics he compiled. Damien reviewed it, and then we went through it all together. So the first thing I thought we'd talk about is the sexual assaults in Cologne.
我事先把本给我的研究资料——他汇编的文章、报告和统计数据——都发给了达米安。达米安审查了它们，然后我们一起过了一遍。所以我认为我们应该谈论的第一件事是科隆的性侵案。
This was the New Year's incident that Ben kept encountering again and again in his research. He'd read and seen that lots of women have been sexually assaulted by Arab men.
这是本在研究中反复遇到的新年事件。他读到并看到许多妇女被阿拉伯男人性侵。
And he believed it to be true.
并且他相信这是事实。
After I met Ben, I read up on this. And if we're being honest, I found the numbers that were being reported hard to believe. The Washington Post and others wrote about more than 1,000 women, primarily in Cologne, but also other German cities, being assaulted by upwards of 2,000 men, according to some reports. Men who were largely migrants.
遇见本之后，我查阅了相关资料。如果坦诚地说，我发现被报道的数字很难让人相信。《华盛顿邮报》和其他媒体写道，根据一些报告，有超过1000名妇女，主要是在科隆，但在其他德国城市也发生了，遭到了2000多名男子的袭击。那些男人大多是移民。
I didn't understand if the assaults were coordinated or more like a spontaneous mob. Plus, there were headlines on sites like Breitbart, such as "New Year Rape Horror" and "Rape-fugees Not Welcome." I just wasn't sure what to think.
我不明白袭击是有组织的，还是更像一种自发的暴民行为。此外，在布赖特巴特这样的网站上有标题，比如“新年强奸恐怖”和“强奸难民不受欢迎”。我不知道该怎么想。
But Damien explained these attacks were real. They happened. He reported on them. There were in fact about 1,000 criminal complaints filed with Cologne Police, about half of those for various levels of sexual assault, including allegations of rape. The other half include theft of purses and phones, and other violence too.
但达米安解释说这些袭击是真实的。它们发生了。他报道了它们。事实上，科隆警方收到了约1000起刑事投诉，其中约一半是针对不同程度的性侵犯，包括强奸指控。另一半包括偷窃钱包和手机，还有其他暴力行为。
There are terrifying accounts of women being surrounded and attacked by men. Damien thinks it's important to understand the pandemonium in German city centers on New Year's Eve, which he says is unlike public parties elsewhere in Europe. There are huge masses of people. It's dark. People were setting off fireworks in the crowd. Damien says what occurred was somewhere between a wild drunken party and a riot that police couldn't control.
有关于妇女被男人包围和袭击的可怕叙述。达米安认为理解新年前夜德国市中心的混乱非常重要，他说这与欧洲其他地方的公共派对不同。有大量的人群。天很黑。人们在人群中燃放烟花。达米安说发生的事情处于疯狂的酒后派对和警察无法控制的暴乱之间。
And the drunkenness on the streets is of a level I don't think you'd really see in the states. And it's not to minimize the trauma that these women underwent, or to say it's any less shocking. But it goes to explain why the police found it hard to control, and helps explain why then criminal elements took advantage of that to do something appalling. It makes it seem less crazy.
街头的醉酒程度是我认为你在美国真的看不到的。这并不是要淡化这些妇女遭受的创伤，或者说这就不那么令人震惊了。但这有助于解释为什么警方发现很难控制，并有助于解释为什么犯罪分子利用这一点做了一些骇人听闻的事情。这让它看起来不那么疯狂。
Most of the suspects were identified. About 150 men, were immigrants and asylum seekers, particularly from North African countries. There are accounts from people who were there of many more men being involved. So what Ben saw about Cologne, while it was sensationalized with words like rape-fugees, was, for the most part, true.
大多数嫌疑人被确定身份了。大约150名男子是移民和寻求庇护者，特别来自北非国家。有现场的人描述有更多的男人参与其中。所以本看到的关于科隆的内容，虽然用“强奸难民”这样的词进行了炒作，但大部分是真实的。
Next, Ben and Damien and I looked at one of the Breitbart articles that made a big impression on Ben. It starts, quote, "A massive migrant crime wave is surging across Germany," end quote, citing a report from the interior ministry that's over 100 pages long and entirely in German. The article says Germany recorded roughly 402,000 crimes committed by migrants in 2015. Damien read the underlying report, and he says that 402,000 number--
接下来，本、达米安和我看了其中一篇让本印象深刻的布赖特巴特文章。它开头引用道：“大规模移民犯罪浪潮正在德国蔓延”，引述了一份长达100多页且完全是德语的内政部报告。文章称，2015年德国记录了大约40.2万起由移民犯下的罪行。达米安读了底层报告，他说那40.2万的数字——
That is correct. That's a correct figure.
那是正确的。那是个正确的数字。
Except--
除了——
This 400,000 figure is actually including the crime of crossing the border as an asylum seeker. Now by definition, that can only be committed by migrants, and in fact, is how most refugees, by legitimately accepted international law, actually apply for asylum.
这个40万的数字实际上包括了作为寻求庇护者越境的犯罪行为。根据定义，这只能由移民犯下，事实上，这是大多数难民根据合法接受的国际法，实际申请庇护的方式。
Now when you take away that particular criminal act of crossing the border, what you then find is actually-- and the government report very clearly says this-- in fact, the crime rates remained pretty much the same 2015 compared to the year before.
现在当你扣除越境的那种特定刑事行为时，你实际上会发现——政府报告非常清楚地说明了这一点——事实上，2015年的犯罪率与前一年相比基本保持不变。
The Breitbart article does say that many of these crimes were border crimes. They don't leave that information out completely. But in reality, that's all that 400,000 number is-- immigration infractions like border crossing or overstaying a visa. It doesn't include any other type of crime.
布赖特巴特文章确实说了其中许多犯罪是边境犯罪。他们并没有完全遗漏该信息。但实际上，那40万数字只是——违反移民规定，如越境或签证逾期。它不包括任何其他类型的犯罪。
They're using proper statistics, but not putting them in the right context. And then they're using alarmist language like, "A massive migrant crime wave is surging across Germany."
他们使用正确的统计数据，但没有放在正确的背景下。然后他们使用恐慌性的语言，比如“大规模移民犯罪浪潮正在德国蔓延”。
Wow.
哇。
Did you understand that, Ben, from reading this article?
本，你在阅读这篇文章时理解这一点了吗？
Man, I didn't get that at all.
伙计，我一点也没明白。
I didn't get it either. I mean, I had to-- I clicked on the link to what they were sourcing, and it's a 135-page report in German.
我也不明白。我是说，我必须——我点击了他们来源的链接，那是一份135页的德语报告。
And it's a complicated report. You know, it's a slog to read through. It's a government report. It's not necessarily very clear itself.
这是一份复杂的报告。你知道，通读它很费劲。这是政府报告。它本身不一定很清楚。
So is a migrant crime wave surging across Germany? Damien tells Ben when you take out those crimes like crossing the border or overstaying a visa, the amount of crime committed by immigrants overall has gone up in the last three years. It's nearly tripled, from 3-1/2% of all crimes to 9%.
那么移民犯罪浪潮是否正在德国蔓延？达米安告诉本，当你除去像越境或逾期居留签证这样的犯罪时，过去三年中移民犯下的犯罪总额确实上升了。它几乎翻了三倍，从占所有犯罪的3.5%上升到9%。
Granted, that's at the same time that a huge number of immigrants have been coming into Germany, a million and a half people. But the increase in immigrant crime still appears to be outstripping that population growth. There are caveats to that too, though. The German government has cautioned that the research on this is not yet sophisticated enough to draw firm conclusions. Also, Damien tells Ben--
诚然，这与大量移民涌入德国的同时发生的，150万人。但移民犯罪的增加似乎仍然超过了人口增长。不过，对此也有告诫。德国政府警告说，对此的研究尚未成熟到足以得出坚定结论的地步。此外，达米安告诉本——
A lot of the rising crime committed by migrants was on other migrants.
许多由移民犯下的日益严重的罪行是针对其他移民的。
According to the interior ministry, migrants were responsible for 4.6% of crimes against German victims and 79% of crimes against immigrant victims. Ben had this picture in his head from the coverage he read of immigrants coming in and victimizing locals. But that's not the reality.
根据内政部的数据，移民应对4.6%的针对德国受害者的犯罪负责，以及79%的针对移民受害者的犯罪。本在读到的报道中脑子里有了这样的画面：移民进来并侵害当地人。但现实并非如此。
It might sound a bit skeptical to say it, but those crimes are not affecting the German population.
说出这一点可能听起来有点怀疑，但这些罪行并没有影响德国人口。
Plus, Damien points out, it's important to bear in mind the situation in which many of these crimes are committed-- in overcrowded, underserved refugee shelters packed with people, many of whom have been traumatized by war and violence in places like Syria and Iraq.
此外，达米安指出，记住许多这些罪行发生的背景非常重要——在人满为患、服务不足的难民收容所，挤满了人，他们中有许多人在叙利亚和伊拉克等地被战争和暴力伤害过。
So without excusing crime, it's clear that these are stressful conditions in which normal people can make bad choices.
因此，在不原谅犯罪的情况下，很明显这些是充满压力的条件，普通人在这种条件下可能会做出错误的选择。
We talked through a few other things Ben found in his research. I tell him that a French speaking colleague and I spoke to several law enforcement sources in France, and they all said the concept of "no-go zones," immigrant neighborhoods where native French people were supposedly not allowed in, are not real.
我们讨论了本在研究中发现的其他几件事。我告诉他，一位讲法语的同事和我与法国的几位执法消息来源谈过，他们都说“禁区”这个概念，即据说法国本地人不允许进入的移民社区，是不存在的。
One of them told us it was, quote, "an American invention." And Damien agrees. He says it's become a bit of a joke in Europe that to Americans, entire cities are no-go zones. Damien also tells Ben about a Breitbart story he had personal experience with from earlier this year, which claimed that a mob of Muslim men had set Germany's oldest church on fire.
其中一人告诉我们它是“美国人的发明”。达米安也表示同意。他说在欧洲，美国人认为整个城市都是禁区已经成为一个笑话。达米安还告诉本一个他亲身经历的、今年早些时候的布赖特巴特故事，声称一群穆斯林男子放火烧毁了德国最古老的教堂。
It included a video of supposed Islamists chanting in the streets nearby and celebrating. Damien remembers seeing that story appear on the internet and then trying to run it down with other journalists, only to find that the church was not Germany's oldest. It had not been set on fire. A stray firework had briefly ignited some netting on some scaffolding, but that was it. And the men celebrating in the video were not Islamists, but actually anti-Islamist. They were Syrian refugees celebrating a ceasefire in the war back home.
它包含了一段视频，据说是伊斯兰主义者在附近街道上高呼口号并庆祝。达米安记得看到那个故事出现在网上，然后试图和其他记者一起去追查，结果发现那座教堂并不是德国最古老的。它并没有被放火烧毁。一枚流弹烟花暂时点燃了脚手架上的一些网，仅此而已。视频中庆祝的人不是伊斯兰主义者，实际上是反伊斯兰主义者。他们是叙利亚难民在庆祝家乡战争停火。
I remember that story. My gosh.
我记得那个故事。天哪。
You remember reading it?
你记得读过它？
Yes.
是的，确实记得。
It was something Ben came across in his research and he believed it.
这是本在研究中遇到的事情，并且他相信了。
So you thought that Islamists burned down Germany's oldest church?
所以你认为伊斯兰主义者烧毁了德国最古老的教堂？
Yes, yes I did. I mean, I had no reason not to. Wow. I'm kind of flabbergasted, actually, and more than a little bit angry at this point.
是的，是的，我确实那么认为。我是说，我没有理由不相信。哇。我实际上有点目瞪口呆，而且现在感到不止一点点的愤怒。
And lastly, we come to the document that helped clinch Ben's decision for him-- his decision that he was opposed to the resolution in Homer. It's that report by the think tank the Gatestone Institute, called The Islamization of Germany, which lists 19 pages of crimes, all linked in some way to Muslims and migrants.
最后，我们谈到了那份帮助巩固本决定的文件——他决定反对荷马市那项决议。就是那份由智库盖特斯通研究所撰写的报告，标题是《德国的伊斯兰化》，列出了19页的罪行，全部以某种方式与穆斯林和移民联系在一起。
Yeah, I'm flicking through the report now. And, you know, if I just take one example. There's a crime on July 22nd, 2016. So I'm reading it now. It says Ali Sonboly, you know, Muslim name--
是的，我正在翻阅这份报告。而且，你知道，如果我只举一个例子。有一个罪行是2016年7月22日。所以我现在正在读它。它说阿里·松博利（Ali Sonboly），你知道，穆斯林名字——
Ali Sonboly, it reads. Quote, "An 18-year-old Iranian German who harbored hatred for Arabs and Turks killed 10 people, including himself, and wounded 35 others at a McDonald's in Munich." That's the whole entry.
“阿里·松博利，”它是这样读的。引述：“一名18岁的伊朗裔德国人，怀着对阿拉伯人和土耳其人的仇恨，在慕尼黑一家麦当劳杀害了10人，包括他自己，并造成35人受伤。”这就是整条条目。
Damien reported on this story as it happened. And first of all, he tells Ben, when it says Sonboly was, quote, "Iranian-German," he was born to Iranian parents, but in Germany. He grew up in Germany, spoke German. He was German. And as for including Sonboly in a report called The Islamization of Germany--
达米安在故事发生时就报道了它。首先，他告诉本，当它说松博利是“伊朗裔德国人”时，他出生于伊朗父母，但在德国。他在德国长大，说德语。他是德国人。至于把松博利包括在一份名为《德国的伊斯兰化》的报告中——
In fact, it was found later that he had large amounts of neo-Nazi memorabilia. He was a great fan of the Norwegian mass murderer Breivik-- you might remember killed all those young people in Norway.
事实上，后来发现他有大量的新纳粹纪念品。他是挪威大规模杀人犯布雷维克（Breivik）的忠实粉丝——你可能记得他在挪威杀害了所有那些年轻人。
He was reportedly very proud of having the same birthday as-- I can't remember if it was Adolf Hitler, or if it was the same birthday as Breivik. And he hated foreigners. Ali Sonboly was not an Islamist. He was a right wing extremist.
据报道，他非常自豪能与阿道夫·希特勒，或者是与布雷维克同一天生日。他仇恨外国人。阿里·松博利不是伊斯兰主义者。他是一个右翼极端分子。
Most of Sonboly's victims were foreigners.
松博利的大多数受害者是外国人。
This should be in a report about anti-foreigner, right wing extremist violence. It's in the wrong report.
这应该出现在一份关于反外国人、右翼极端暴力行为的报告中。它出现在了错误的报告里。
Damien says since 1991, Islamist attacks have caused 14 deaths in Germany. In the same time period, he says, there have been approximately 150 deaths at the hands of right wing extremists in the country. And according to the government, right wing violence increased dramatically as the big wave of migrants started coming in. But Ben came across none of this in his research.
达米安说，自1991年以来，伊斯兰主义者的袭击在德国造成了14人死亡。在同一时期，他说，该国大约有150人死于右翼极端分子之手。而且根据政府的数据，随着大规模移民开始涌入，右翼暴力急剧增加。但本在研究中根本没有遇到任何这些信息。
I wondered what Ben was thinking during all this. And I was surprised to hear him say this.
我想知道本在这一切中在想什么。听到他这么说，我很惊讶。
It's definitely making me lean toward the thought that I was wrong.
这绝对让我倾向于认为我是错的。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
You think you were like wrong wrong?
你认为你错了？
Yes. I mean, not through lack of trying. But I think I was wrong.
是的。我是说，不是我不努力。但我认为我是错的。
He thinks he was wrong in his conclusion that immigration makes places more unsafe. Ben meant so well, tried so hard to be skeptical, to be fact based, to find the truth, and still he feels he was led astray.
他认为他在移民使地方变得更不安全的结论上错了。本出于好意，非常努力地去保持怀疑，去以事实为基础，去寻找真相，然而他仍然感到被误导了。
A lot of that he chalks up to him being such a novice to news. He says it seems to him that the sources he was reading, like Breitbart and the report from the Gatestone Institute-- which is a right wing think tank, chaired by former U.N. Ambassador under George W. Bush, John Bolton-- were successful in doing what they were designed to do. Sway him against immigration. But it's also true that Ben took himself to those sources.
其中很多原因归结于他是一个新闻初学者。他说在他看来，他正在阅读的来源，比如布赖特巴特和盖特斯通研究所的报告——那是一家右翼智库，由乔治·W·布什时期的前联合国大使约翰·博尔顿（John Bolton）担任主席——成功地做了它们被设计用来做的事情。让他反对移民。但本自己去寻找这些来源也是事实。
I think the conclusion I've come to is that I was picking this information. And part of it was irrational fear. I admit that.
我想我得出的结论是，我是在挑选这些信息。其中一部分是无理的恐惧。我承认这一点。
I wouldn't have put so much time into it if I hadn't been afraid. I think the fear just kind of fed on itself. I mean, I told you before, I try to be unemotional about this stuff, but the more I think about it, the more I think that I may-- that I was more emotional than I like to let myself believe. And it skewed my thinking.
如果我不是因为害怕，就不会投入这么多时间。我想恐惧只是在喂养自身。我是说，我之前告诉过你，我试着对这些东西保持冷漠，但我想得越多，我就越觉得——我当时比我喜欢让自己相信的要情绪化得多。这扭曲了我的思维。
Ben was not the only person in Homer who brought up Europe and specifically Germany with me, as we were discussing immigration. This is the weird moment the world is in right now, where people at the end of the road in Alaska are examining Germany to decide their feelings on a local city resolution.
本并不是荷马市唯一一个和我讨论移民问题时提到欧洲、特别是德国的人。这就是当今世界奇怪的时刻，阿拉斯加道路尽头的人们正在审查德国，来决定他们对本地城市决议的感受。
While Ben does feel he was wrong to fear immigration, he doesn't think he was wrong to encourage his city government to be cautious if it were to invite a lot of immigrants in. He wants to have open arms. But he still believes it's important to have a plan in place for everyone's safety. And he's still not sure what the right way to do that is.
虽然本确实觉得他害怕移民是错的，但他并不认为鼓励他的市政府保持谨慎（如果它要邀请大量移民进来的话）是错的。他想敞开双臂。但他仍然认为为每个人的安全制定计划是很重要的。而且他仍然不确定这样做正确的途径是什么。
It's a very difficult dichotomy to work through, because I do want to help people, but I'm also afraid of them. I'm still trying to figure it out. I'm still trying to marry those two things together.
这是一个非常困难的二分法，因为我确实想帮助人，但我又害怕他们。我仍在试图搞清楚。我仍在试图将这两件事结合在一起。
Well, you're doing exactly what nations are trying to figure out now, too. How to stay safe and not be afraid, but also help people. Like, that's what Germany seems to be going through, right, Damien?
嗯，你做的正是国家现在也正在试图搞清楚的事情。如何保持安全而不害怕，同时也能帮助别人。比如，这就是德国似乎正在经历的事情，对吧，达米安？
Yeah.
是的。
And that's what the US is debating too.
这也是美国正在辩论的事情。
Well, I'm glad I'm not the only one.
嗯，我很高兴我不是唯一一个。
Yeah, that's like the question the world's going through right now.
是的，这就像世界现在正在经历的问题。
And that world includes Homer, Alaska.
而那个世界包括阿拉斯加的荷马市。
Brian Reed. He's the senior producer of our program and the host of the podcast S-Town, which is about another small town, that one in Alabama. Coming up, we return to the lower 48, to a high school in Maryland, and an incident that even got the president's attention. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
布莱恩·里德。他是我们节目的高级制片人，也是播客《S-Town》的主持人，该播客是关于另一个小镇的，那个小镇在阿拉巴马州。接下来，我们将回到美国本土，回到马里兰州的一所高中，以及一起甚至引起总统注意的事件。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共电台，当我们的节目继续时。
This American Life, from Ira Glass. Today's program, "Fear and Loathing in Homer and Rockville." We have two stories of places where people got really scared about immigrants, where immigration did not seem to be the main thing going on. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Loathing. So the first half of our program was about a community that was worried about what might happen, theoretically, if undocumented immigrants arrived. This next story happens in a place where they actually already have arrived-- Rockville, Maryland, a suburb of Washington, D.C., where this winter, something actually did happen. And the whole community had to deal with it. Zoe Chace explains.
《美国生活》，来自艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天的节目，“荷马和罗克维尔的恐惧与厌恶”。我们有两个关于人们对移民感到非常害怕的地方的故事，那里的移民问题似乎根本不是当地发生的主要事情。我们已经进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，厌恶。所以我们节目的前半部分是关于一个社区担心如果无证移民到达会发生什么（理论上）。接下来的这个故事发生在他们实际上已经到达的地方——马里兰州的罗克维尔，华盛顿特区的一个郊区，今年冬天，真的发生了一些事情。整个社区都不得不处理它。佐伊·查斯（Zoe Chace）来解释。
Here's the thing that happened. A freshman girl in the local high school said she was raped by two undocumented immigrant students. She said it happened at 9:00 on a Thursday morning, in the boys' bathroom at the school.
发生的事情是这样的。当地高中的一名新生女生说，她被两名无证移民学生强奸了。她说这发生在周四早上9点，在学校的男生洗手间。
The boys were new students. They'd crossed the border separately from El Salvador and Guatemala. Jose was 17. Henry was 18. The girl was 14. They were all ninth graders, though.
这两个男孩是新生。他们分别从萨尔瓦多和危地马拉越过边境。何塞（Jose）17岁。亨利（Henry）18岁。女生14岁。虽然他们都是九年级的学生。
The superintendent of schools, Jack Smith-- was the person who'd have to manage the situation. The police, the parents, the students, the press. I talked to him while he was dealing with all that, back in March.
学校校长杰克·史密斯（Jack Smith）——是不得不管理这种情况的人。警方、家长、学生、媒体。三月份的时候，我在他处理这些事情时采访了他。
I couldn't understand how it could have happened in a busy high school with 1,500 students and a large staff. Felt sick at my stomach. So I was confused as to what could have happened.
我无法理解这怎么会在一所拥有1500名学生和大量教职员工的繁忙高中发生。我感到恶心。所以我很困惑到底发生了什么。
In less than 24 hours, TV trucks were showing up at the school. Local television and radio, mostly.
不到24小时，电视转播车就出现在学校了。主要是当地电视和电台。
Parents shocked to learn a 14-year-old girl was allegedly raped by two fellow Rockville High students. It happened Thursday, around 9:00 AM. The charging documents describe a horrific ordeal.
家长们震惊地得知一名14岁女生据称被两名罗克维尔高中的同学强奸。这发生在周四早上9点左右。指控文件描述了一段可怕的经历。
The early reporting described the boys as undocumented immigrants. And as the days went on, that became the focus of a lot of the coverage-- the boys' immigration status.
早期的报道描述这些男孩是无证移民。随着时间的推移，这成了很多报道的焦点——男孩们的移民身份。
Well, good evening, and welcome to Tucker Carlson Tonight. Just days ago, a hideous crime was allegedly committed in the Washington, D.C. suburb of Rockville, Maryland.
晚上好，欢迎收看《塔克·卡尔森今晚秀》（Tucker Carlson Tonight）。就在几天前，华盛顿特区郊区马里兰州罗克维尔发生了一起令人发指的罪行。
Fox News covered the case in Rockville every day, the Tucker Carlson show in particular.
福克斯新闻每天都在报道罗克维尔的案件，特别是塔克·卡尔森的节目。
Sanchez is 18 years old and in this country illegally. But instead of being deported back to his country of origin, he was instead placed in the ninth grade and educated at taxpayer expense. This is insanity, of course. It's a sign of a sick civilization at war with itself.
桑切斯（Sanchez）18岁，在这个国家非法居留。但他没有被驱逐回原籍国，而是被安排在九年级，并由纳税人出钱接受教育。这当然是疯狂的。这是一个正在自我战争的病态文明的标志。
That was the general tone of the coverage on Fox. This rape allegation is a great example of how terrible our immigration policies are. They turned the case into a referendum. You didn't see much coverage of the allegation on other major news networks.
这就是福克斯报道的基调。这起强奸指控是我们的移民政策有多糟糕的一个很好的例子。他们把这个案件变成了一次公投。你在其他主要新闻网络上没看到多少关于该指控的报道。
In the week after, it was mentioned only twice on CNN, once in The New York Times. Local D.C. TV and local papers, like The Washington Post and The Washington Times-- they stayed on it. But Fox News and other online conservative media, they did not skip a day that week. The school superintendent Jack Smith, watched the story take off.
在一周之后，它只在CNN上提到过两次，在《纽约时报》上提到过一次。当地的华盛顿特区电视台和当地报纸，如《华盛顿邮报》和《华盛顿时报》——他们一直关注它。但福克斯新闻和其他在线保守派媒体，那一周一天都没落下。学校校长杰克·史密斯，看着这个故事起飞。
We just watched it grow over Friday, Friday night, Saturday, thinking, you know, how do we separate this-- the horrific situation-- from the immigration debate? And knowing that we weren't going to be able to. I mean, you couldn't have lived through the last 18 months in the United States and not have been inundated with the perspectives on those things.
我们只是看着它在周五、周五晚上、周六增长，思考着，你知道，我们怎么才能把这——那种可怕的情况——从移民辩论中分离出来？并且知道我们做不到。我的意思是，你不可能在过去18个月里生活在美国，却没有被那些观点所淹没。
Jack Smith was named in the coverage as the guy responsible for the schools. And voicemails and emails started pouring into the school district from all over the country with a clear message for him.
杰克·史密斯在报道中被点名为负责学校的人。来自全国各地的语音信箱和邮件开始涌入学校区，向他传达了一个明确的信息。
01:00 AM.
凌晨1点。
Yes, hello, to the wonderful school board that hired a Jack Smith. I'd like to say I'm the father of three young girls that were not raped by illegal aliens. Fire this man. And hopefully all the rest of you nitwits at that school board will be fired next for letting illegal aliens in.
是的，你好，聘请了杰克·史密斯的精彩校董会。我想说我是三个年轻女孩的父亲，她们没有被非法外星人（即非法移民）强奸。解雇这个人。希望你们校董会剩下的那些笨蛋也会因为让非法外星人进来而被解雇。
Read the constitution. They are illegals. They should not be in the school system, period. Get it through your heads. They are illegals. Thank you very much.
读读宪法。他们是非法的。他们不应该进入学校系统，句号。动动你们的脑子。他们是非法的。非常感谢。
The President of the United States weighed in, via his spokesman Sean Spicer, at the White House press briefing.
美国总统通过他在白宫新闻发布会的发言人肖恩·斯派塞（Sean Spicer）表达了看法。
This is a tragic event. And it's horrendous, and horrible, and disgusting, what this young woman in Rockville went through. I can't possibly imagine. So first of all, let's remember the human side of this. That this is a tragic event. This is why he's passionate about this.
这是一个悲剧事件。这是可怕的，恐怖的，令人厌恶的，这个年轻女性在罗克维尔经历的一切。我无法想象。所以首先，让我们记住人性的一面。这是一个悲剧事件。这就是为什么他会对这些事情充满激情。
Why Donald Trump is passionate about spotlighting crimes committed by undocumented immigrants.
为什么唐纳德·特朗普会对曝光非法移民犯下的罪行充满激情。
Because people are victims of these crimes. Immigration pays its toll on our people if it's done-- if it's not done legally. And this is another example. And it's why the--
因为人们是这些罪行的受害者。如果不以合法方式进行，移民会对我们的人民造成损失。这就是另一个例子。这就是为什么——
At this point, the superintendent Jack Smith decides he needs to do a press conference himself. Suddenly it seems like everyone in the country had this one question for him, which was, why do you allow illegal immigrants at your schools? Jack Smith's answer came at that press conference.
此时，校长杰克·史密斯决定亲自召开新闻发布会。突然之间，全国每个人似乎都有一个问题要问他，那就是，你为什么要允许非法移民进入你的学校？杰克·史密斯的回答是在那次新闻发布会上给出的。
What comes down here is that we serve every student that walks in our door. We are a public school system, and we serve all of our students when they come to us. And when we look at that, it is not only the right thing to do, and the good thing to do, and it benefits the students and our community-- it's also the law of the land. And it's what--
归根结底是我们服务每一个走进我们大门的每个学生。我们是一个公立学校系统，当他们来找我们时，我们服务于我们所有的学生。当我们审视这一点时，这不仅是正确的事情，是好的事情，并且对学生和我们的社区有益——这还是国家的法律。这就是——
He talks about the Supreme Court case, Plyler v. Doe, which says students can't be denied a free public education based on their immigration status. We don't even know anyone's status, he says, because it's against the law to collect that. We serve every student in front of us. That's it. Meanwhile, back at Fox, on the second day of Tucker Carlson's nightly coverage of the case, he brought up the superintendent's press conference.
他谈到了最高法院案件，Plyler v. Doe，该案件规定不能基于移民身份拒绝学生获得免费公共教育。我们甚至不知道任何人的身份，他说，因为收集该信息是违法的。我们服务于我们面前的每一个学生。就是这样。与此同时，回到福克斯，在塔克·卡尔森每晚报道该案的第二天，他提到了校长的发布会。
Top officials there don't want to think about the connection illegal immigration might have to this crime or others like it. Montgomery County School Superintendent Jack Smith, for instance, said this.
那里的高层不想考虑非法移民可能与此罪行或其他类似罪行有什么联系。例如，蒙哥马利县学校校长杰克·史密斯说。
We're not going to paint all students who speak another language, all students of a skin color, all students of a religion, with a broad brush because of a really terrible incident. So I'm saying no tonight. We're going to take care of our students.
我们不会因为一起真正可怕的事件，就给所有讲另一种语言的学生、所有肤色的学生、所有宗教的学生贴上标签。所以我今晚说不。我们将照顾好我们的学生。
In other words, diversity is our strength, move along, you're racist, shut up. Thanks, Jack. Why are people embarrassed to point to something that actually happened and draw obvious conclusions from it?
换句话说，多样性是我们的力量，继续前进吧，你是种族主义者，闭嘴。谢谢，杰克。为什么人们对于指出实际发生的事情并得出明显的结论感到尴尬？
Calls and emails coming into the school district just exploded after this broadcast.
在这次广播之后，打进校区的电话和邮件爆炸式增长。
I'm calling after seeing the story about opening that meeting, calling people bigots who don't like illegal aliens in their schools. I think you're a [BLEEP] idiot. And, you know what, this call is indicative of thousands and thousands of other people. I know you don't give a [BLEEP].
我在看到关于开放那个会议的故事后打电话，称那些不喜欢非法外星人在他们学校里的人为偏执狂。我认为你是个[哔]白痴。你知道吗，这个电话代表了成千上万的其他人的意见。我知道你根本不在乎[哔]。
People were so mad they mixed up their prejudices into a big stew of things they don't like.
人们太愤怒了，以至于把他们的偏见混合成了一锅他们不喜欢的炖菜。
I understand that Jack Smith is telling a 14-year-old to be sensitive to the Muslims' needs and not be xenophobic after the Muslims raped a 14-year-old girl.
我理解杰克·史密斯告诉一个14岁的人要对穆斯林的需求敏感，在穆斯林强奸了一个14岁女孩后不要排外，这太可笑了。
The accused Hispanic boys were not Muslim.
被指控的西班牙裔男孩不是穆斯林。
For this man to come out and call the people that their daughter, who was raped, homophobic, this is ridiculous.
对于这个男人出来称呼那些女儿被强奸的人为恐同者，这是荒谬的。
Racist, not homophobic, according to Tucker Carlson. The calls coming into the school got threatening. Someone threatened to shoot every immigrant student in the school. Someone sent an email saying "I'm going to burn that school down." The school added extra security.
根据塔克·卡尔森的说法是种族主义，而不是恐同。打进学校的电话开始带有威胁性。有人威胁要枪杀学校里的每一个移民学生。有人发邮件说“我要把那所学校烧了”。学校增加了额外的安保。
Just like in Homer, Alaska, the place we went in the first half of the show, the conversation about immigration had moved from the real to the totally symbolic. But their anger wasn't about an imagined hypothetical menace. It was about real people, the immigrant students at Rockville High School, and their superintendent. Again, Jack Smith.
就像在阿拉斯加的荷马市，我们在节目上半部分去的地方一样，关于移民的对话已经从真实的变成了完全象征性的。但他们的愤怒并不是关于一个想象中的假设威胁。它是关于真实的人，罗克维尔高中的移民学生和他们的校长。再次是杰克·史密斯。
Up until just a day or two ago, I've gotten the ugliest, most hateful, most vile, most sickening emails. Some of them name my wife and my five adult children by name, and spell their names right. Some of them say I know where you live. It freaked me out.
直到一两天前，我收到了最丑陋、最充满仇恨、最卑鄙、最令人作呕的电子邮件。其中一些用名字点出了我妻子和我五个成年子女的名字，并且拼写正确。一些说我知道你住在哪里。这让我吓坏了。
What did your wife say?
你妻子说了什么？
She was afraid. She was freaked out. And I showed her some of the messages I was getting. And she said, I'm sorry we moved here. I'm sorry you took this job. I hate it. And I said, I know, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
她很害怕。她被吓坏了。我给她看了我收到的一些信息。她说，我后悔我们搬到这里。我后悔你接受这份工作。我讨厌它。我说，我知道，我很抱歉，我很抱歉。
Within weeks, the story changed. New evidence came forward. Text messages, video camera evidence, physical evidence.
几周内，情况变了。新证据浮出水面。短信、摄像机证据、物理证据。
We have concluded that the facts in this case do not support the original charges filed in this matter.
我们得出的结论是，本案的事实不支持在此事项中提交的原始指控。
After a month and a half, the state's attorney decides to drop the rape charges.
一个半月后，州检察官决定放弃强奸指控。
Due to the lack of corroboration and substantial inconsistencies from the facts that we have obtained from multiple sources, the original charges cannot be sustained and prosecution on those charges is untenable.
由于缺乏确证，并且从我们从多个来源获得的事实中存在实质性矛盾，原始指控无法维持，对这些指控的起诉是站不住脚的。
The prosecution couldn't back up the girl's narrative of events. She said she was forced into the bathroom. But that wasn't backed up on the videotape from the hallway. She said she didn't know the boys. But she had been sexting with one of them the night before. The texts showed they planned to meet in the bathroom.
检方无法支持这个女孩对事件的陈述。她说她被迫进入洗手间。但走廊里的录像并没有支持这一点。她说她不认识这些男孩。但前一天晚上她一直在和其中一个发色情短信。短信显示他们计划在洗手间见面。
I cannot tell you if this girl was raped. All I can say is that the lawyers say the incident didn't have the evidence to support her claim of rape in a court of law. It can also say that in a high school of teenagers, two older boys having sex with a younger girl, a 14-year-old girl, in a bathroom at 9:00 in the morning-- it's worrisome, any way you look at it.
我不能告诉你这个女孩是否被强奸了。我只能说律师们说该事件没有证据在法庭上支持她关于强奸的说法。它也可以说，在青少年的高中里，两个大一点的男孩在早上9点在洗手间和一个年轻女孩，一个14岁的女孩发生性关系——无论你从哪个角度看，这都是令人担心的。
I feel upset talking about it. I felt upset hearing about it. I tried reaching out to the girl through the law firm that was representing her multiple times, but they didn't respond. Under Maryland law, these kids are too close in age for this to be statutory rape. The state did decide to charge the boys with something else-- child pornography.
谈论它让我感到心烦。听到它让我感到心烦。我多次尝试通过代表她的律师事务所联系这个女孩，但他们没有回应。根据马里兰州法律，这些孩子年龄太接近，不属于法定强奸。州政府确实决定以其他罪名指控这些男孩——儿童色情罪。
The girl had sent one of the boys naked pictures and videos of herself, and he forwarded them on to the other kid. So Henry, who's 18, remains in jail. Jose, who's 17, was released, and then picked up by ICE that same day. He's now in the custody of Immigration Enforcement.
那个女孩给其中一个男孩发了她自己的裸体照片和视频，他把它们转发给了另一个孩子。所以18岁的亨利仍被关在监狱里。17岁的何塞被释放了，然后当天就被ICE抓走了。他现在处于移民执法局的监护下。
I wanted to talk to someone who took this dark, complicated situation involving teenagers and decided the most important thing about it was what it said about our immigration system. The people whose reporting unleashed a flood of threats on that school. I wanted to ask, why do that? I wanted to hear their rationale-- like, what were they trying to achieve?
我想和一个把这种黑暗、复杂、涉及青少年的情况拿出来，并决定关于它的最重要的事情是它说明了我们的移民制度的人交谈。那些报道引发了学校威胁潮的人。我想问，为什么要这样做？我想听听他们的理由——比如，他们想实现什么？
And I asked Tucker Carlson. He turned me down for an interview. But I got someone close.
我问了塔克·卡尔森。他拒绝了我的采访。但我找到了一个接近的人。
We are talking about cultures that are just behind ours. They are backwards. They're behind us in tolerance, eating with a knife and fork.
我们谈论的是那些落后于我们的文化。他们是落后的。他们在宽容度、用刀叉吃饭方面落后于我们。
Ann Coulter. Yeah, I called Ann Coulter. Notorious right wing columnist, major influencer behind Trump's immigration policies during the campaign. She'd written a column about the case right after the charges were dropped, titled, "To Say, 'Stop Raping Me!' In English, Press '1' Now."
安·库尔特（Ann Coulter）。是的，我打了安·库尔特的电话。臭名昭著的右翼专栏作家，特朗普竞选期间移民政策背后的主要影响者。在指控撤销后，她写了一篇关于此案的专栏，标题是《现在要用英语说“停止强奸我！”，按“1”》。
Her book, Adios America, has multiple chapters focusing on sexual assault cases committed by undocumented immigrants. And to anyone who would call it racist or xenophobic to make the Rockville case about immigration, she says--
她的书，《再见美国》（Adios America），有多个章节专门关注无证移民犯下的性侵案。对于任何称将罗克维尔案件与移民联系起来是种族主义或排外的人，她说——
Yes, I'm instantly saying F you.
是的，我立刻要说“去你的”。
This is her reaction when I show her a letter the superintendent Jack Smith sent home to parents, which includes a line condemning racist and xenophobic threats against students.
这是当我给她看校长杰克·史密斯发给家长的信时她的反应，其中包含一行谴责针对学生的种族主义和排外威胁。
Oh, [BLEEP] him.
哦，[哔]他。
So what's the part?
那部分是什么？
While many of you have engaged in-- crossed the line with racist, xenophobic calls and emails-- oh, boo hoo hoo. A 14-year-old girl was at least statutorily gang raped.
“虽然你们中的许多人参与了——越过了种族主义、排外电话和邮件的界线——哦，呜呜呜。一个14岁的女孩至少在法定上被轮奸了。”
But the racist, xenophobic calls also affect other students in the school.
但种族主义、排外电话也影响了学校里的其他学生。
I think now is not the time to be discussing that. Right now, a girl has been raped. People are angry about it. And they are expressing anger. And he turns around and attacks the people expressing anger by calling them names.
我认为现在不是讨论那个的时候。现在，一个女孩被强奸了。人们对此很愤怒。他们正在表达愤怒。他转过身来，通过叫他们的名字来攻击表达愤怒的人。
When do you want to hear about xenophobia?
你什么时候想听关于排外的问题？
When it's a problem. Right now, illegal immigration's a problem.
当它是个问题的时候。现在，非法移民是个问题。
Ann does not believe the prosecutor should have dropped the charges. She doesn't believe the evidence is ambiguous or problematic. She believes unequivocally this was rape.
安不认为检察官应该撤销指控。她不认为证据是模棱两可或成问题的。她毫不含糊地认为这就是强奸。
I played Ann some of the voicemails that poured into the school, after her and others' coverage of the incident. Was that the response she was hoping for? Or was she at least OK with that response?
我给安播放了她和其他人报道该事件后涌入学校的一些语音留言。那是她所希望的反应吗？或者她至少对那个反应感到满意吗？
7:59 AM.
早上7:59。
Too bad you didn't rape the mother [BLEEP] who's responsible to let these mother [BLEEP] in.
太糟糕了，你没有强奸那个负责让这些母亲[哔]进来的人。
Ann reaches for her nicotine gum and considers this. She is unsurprised.
安拿了她的尼古丁口香糖，考虑了一下。她并不感到意外。
I think what you're hearing in the anger here-- it is the frustration and the feeling that there's nothing you can do. And frankly, it's going to get worse because they just put a completely implausible reality TV star in the White House hoping to end it. And so far, he's not ending it. If he betrays them, oh, my gosh, you're going to get a lot more messages like that.
我认为你在这里听到的愤怒——是挫折感和那种你无能为力的感觉。坦率地说，这会变得更糟，因为他们刚刚把一个完全荒谬的真人秀明星送进白宫，希望结束这一切。到目前为止，他并没有结束它。如果他背叛他们，哦，天哪，你会收到更多那样的信息。
Basically, if Trump doesn't crack down on immigration like he said he would, the Jack Smiths of the world are going to get a lot more calls like this. Her message to them-- stop whining.
基本上，如果特朗普不像他说的那样打击移民，像杰克·史密斯这样的人会收到更多这样的电话。她对他们的信息——别发牢骚了。
Now they know what it feels like to be Ann Coulter for a day.
现在他们知道当一天安·库尔特是什么感觉了。
I get the feeling that maybe Ann Coulter gets a lot of death threats in her line of work.
我有种感觉，也许安·库尔特在她的工作岗位上收到了很多死亡威胁。
It's gone on with me long enough that I can tell you, well, not only have I never whined in public about it, but if they call first, they're not coming. These are just people leaving nasty messages.
这发生在我身上已经够久了，我可以告诉你，不仅我从来没有在公开场合发过牢骚，而且如果他们先打电话，他们就不会来了。这些只是留下令人讨厌信息的人。
Well, people said they were going to come and shoot up the school because there were so many illegal immigrants there. I mean, that was a threat that was being made at the school.
嗯，人们说他们要来学校扫射，因为那里有这么多非法移民。我是说，那是学校面临的一个威胁。
OK, some nut makes a phone call. I think the real issue here is we have illegal immigrants raping 14-year-old girls-- allegedly. [LAUGHS]
好吧，某个疯子打了个电话。我认为这里真正的问题是我们有非法移民在强奸14岁的女孩——据称。[笑]
Thank you.
谢谢。
We talked for two and a half hours, and she helped me understand why she wrote about this-- why she thinks it was necessary and important to turn this incident into a case study about the evils of immigration. And her explanation surprised me. She said she and Tucker Carlson, they're not saying this stuff to make people angry.
我们谈了两个半小时，她帮助我理解了她为什么要写这个——为什么她认为把这起事件变成一个关于移民罪恶的案例研究是必要和重要的。她的解释让我感到惊讶。她说她和塔克·卡尔森，他们说这些东西并不是为了让人们生气。
People are already angry, she says, because no one in power is listening to them. Not the schools, not the policy makers, definitely not the media. So Ann's columns-- her screaming angry columns-- that's not trying to rile those people up. That's Ann screaming at the rest of the media for ignoring the fact that so many people are so angry, she thinks. She's screaming because the rest of the media is not. And she says what we're hearing on the school's voicemails is people's anger over this.
人们已经很生气了，她说，因为掌权的人没有人听他们说。不是学校，不是政策制定者，绝对不是媒体。所以安的专栏——她那尖叫的愤怒专栏——那不是为了煽动那些人。那是安在对媒体的其他部分尖叫，因为他们忽视了这么多人如此生气的事实。她尖叫是因为媒体的其他部分没有。她说我们在学校语音留言中听到的是人们对此的愤怒。
They are getting very, very frustrated. And no one is listening to them. And the media is sneering at them and hiding stories that are important to their lives.
他们正变得非常、非常沮丧。没有人听他们说。媒体在嘲笑他们，并隐瞒对他们的生活很重要的故事。
I don't think, though, that the callers are frustrated that the mainstream media is not reporting on it, which I think you are. The callers are antagonized, or whipped up by what Tucker's reporting, and calling the school, and threatening the superintendent. That's what it seems like the order of operations was.
虽然我不认为，打来电话的人是因为主流媒体没有报道而感到沮丧，虽然我认为你是这样。打来电话的人是被塔克的报道激怒或煽动，然后打电话给学校，威胁校长。那看起来是操作顺序。
Well, it's all a part of the same thing-- ignoring the problem of illegal immigration, whether it's the immigration bureaucracy, the schools employing them, the taxes going to pay for them. I mean, in some ways the media is a safety valve.
好吧，这一切都是同一件事的一部分——忽视非法移民的问题，无论是移民官僚机构、雇用他们的学校，还是去支付他们的税收。我是说，在某些方面，媒体是一个安全阀。
The media as a safety valve. Ann thinks if the media reflected the anger of people who are upset about illegal immigration, then those people would be less virulent with their threats, and their voicemails, and their emails, and their Facebook posts. Like this is how she thinks the news should look. Take the very first Washington Post story about this which ran in the metro section with the headline-- Two Students Charged After Rape at Maryland High School.
媒体作为安全阀。安认为如果媒体反映了那些对非法移民感到不满的人的愤怒，那么这些人就不会对他们的威胁、语音留言、电子邮件和Facebook帖子那么刻毒。比如这看起来应该是新闻的样子。看看第一篇报道这件事的《华盛顿邮报》文章，它登在都市版，标题是——两名学生在马里兰高中强奸后被指控。
What should the Washington Post have said if you could have been the editor of that story?
如果你能成为那个故事的编辑，你应该怎么说？
I would have put it on the front page!
我会把它放在头版！
And you would have said? What would the headline...
你会说？标题会是什么……
Immigration policy implicated in the suburbs. Or implicated in rape in the suburbs...implication or immigration seen as factor...no, as cause! They wouldn't have been here if we had a wall. Another argument for Trump's wall.
移民政策牵涉到郊区。或者牵涉到郊区的强奸……牵涉或移民被视为因素……不，作为起因！如果我们有一堵墙，他们就不会在这儿了。这是特朗普之墙的另一个论据。
Hm. But then being immigrants doesn't necessarily have to do with the raping.
嗯。但身为移民不一定非要和强奸有关。
Who cares. These rapists would not have been here.
谁在乎。这些强奸犯本不会在这里的。
I just thought that it was so much more about immigration policy, and it really seems like it's a media criticism.
我只是觉得这更多是关于移民政策，而这看起来确实是对媒体的批评。
Yes, over their defense of illegal immigration.
是的，因为他们对非法移民的辩护。
There is no evidence that being born somewhere else leads people to commit more crimes than if they were born right here in the US. The numbers that exist just don't prove that out. There are all these fears being whipped up around the country about this perceived national menace, but inside Rockville High School, there were fears just about walking down the hallway.
没有证据表明出生在其他地方的人比出生在美国的人更容易犯罪。现有的数字并没有证明这一点。全国到处都是关于这种感知到的国家威胁的恐惧，但在罗克维尔高中内部，有仅仅关于走在走廊里的恐惧。
I guess in the point of view of a girl, the girls felt unsafe. You know, they didn't want to go to the bathroom. They're like I'm scared now.
我猜站在女孩的角度，女孩们感到不安全。你知道，她们不想去洗手间。她们像是我现在很害怕。
This is Keydie, ninth grader at Rockville High School. She's Hispanic. Her parents are from Honduras.
这是基迪（Keydie），罗克维尔高中的九年级学生。她是西班牙裔。她的父母来自洪都拉斯。
She's one of those girls who seems like she just came into her own, like recently transitioned over from kid to young adult. In the weeks and months since the alleged rape in the bathroom, and the national firestorm that came after it, the fears of her and her classmates took on different forms. She felt scared as a Honduran American, and as the daughter of immigrants.
她是那些看起来刚刚成长起来的女孩之一，就像最近从孩子过渡到年轻成年人一样。在洗手间涉嫌强奸案以及随之而来的全国性风暴之后的几周和几个月里，她和同学们的恐惧以不同的形式出现。她作为一个洪都拉斯裔美国人，和一个移民的女儿，感到害怕。
And then, for the immigrant-- I guess the Hispanic students in our school-- they were at a point where they were feeling judged and scared, because they were thinking that the guy who did this was being more accused due to the fact that he's Hispanic, you know? He's being judged even more. Like, if we do something now, they're going to kick us out of the school or something, because we don't have papers.
然后，对于移民——我猜是我们学校的西班牙裔学生——他们处于一种感到被评判和害怕的状态，因为他们认为做这件事的人仅仅因为他是西班牙裔而被更多地指责，你知道吗？他被评判得更多。比如，如果我们现在做什么，他们会把我们踢出学校什么的，因为我们没有证件。
And she felt scared as a girl.
而且她作为一个女孩感到害怕。
I was scared-- what if something like that could happen to me. Because I don't know all the people in my school. Like, I don't know their intentions. Like, they could seem nice, but I don't know if they want to have a nice friendship and whatnot. Like, you don't know what to expect. Like, you just can't be trusting people like that.
我很害怕——如果那样的事情发生在我身上怎么办。因为我不认识学校里的所有人。比如，我不知道他们的意图。比如，他们看起来可能很友好，但我不知道他们是否想有很好的友谊什么的。比如，你不知道会发生什么。比如，你就是不能那样信任人。
It's like all the students were afraid for different reasons at the same time.
就像所有的学生同时因为不同的原因感到害怕一样。
Exactly.
正是如此。
That's lots of people right now. Lots of people are afraid for different reasons at the same time.
现在很多人都是这样。很多人同时因为不同的原因感到害怕。
Zoe Chace is one of the producers of our show.
佐伊·查斯是我们节目的制片人之一。
Our program was produced today by Jonathan Menjivar. Our staff includes Elise Bergerson, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, [INAUDIBLE], Sean Cole, Whitney Dangerfield, Neil Drumming, Karen Duffin, Stephanie Foo, Kimberly Henderson, Miki Meek, Robyn Semien, Christopher [INAUDIBLE], Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, and Julie Whitaker. Senior producers, Brian Reed, Diane Wu, and Ben [INAUDIBLE] worked on today's show.
我们的节目今天由乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）制作。我们的团队包括艾莉丝·伯格森（Elise Bergerson）、苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、佐伊·查斯、[听不清]、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、惠特尼·丹格菲尔德（Whitney Dangerfield）、尼尔·德拉明（Neil Drumming）、凯伦·达芬（Karen Duffin）、斯蒂芬妮·傅（Stephanie Foo）、金伯利·亨德森（Kimberly Henderson）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、克里斯托弗·[听不清]、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）、南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）和朱莉·惠特克（Julie Whitaker）。高级制片人布莱恩·里德、黛安·吴（Diane Wu）和本·[听不清]参与了今天的节目。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.Org. This American Life distributed by public radio stations, by PRX, The Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he knew a lot of people in Montreal speak French, but man, he went to Paris, and heard people speaking--
我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.Org。《美国生活》由公共广播电台、PRX（公共广播交换中心）发行。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚先生（Mr. Torey Malatia）。你知道，他知道蒙特利尔有很多人说法语，但伙计，他去了巴黎，听到人们说——
Wow, in Europe? Of all places, this is happening in Europe?
哇，在欧洲？在所有地方中，这竟然发生在欧洲？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着《美国生活》的更多故事回来。